so i'm going to be a real big cheese
ball and probably deliver this really
poorly right now but
do you know
what i'm looking at right now
what's like a line from the movie
oh my gosh behind one of my favorite yes
i mean that's the real line i'm looking
at the people behind one of my favorite
movies of 2022. oh thanks i feel very
confident in saying that even this early
in the year wow that's that means so
much i can't congratulate you enough
i also am a big believer that we don't
see enough barbat mitzvah movies yes out
there so this brought me back to the
good old days and it did make me wonder
13 year old you if you could go back in
the day and create a bar and bat mitzvah
theme of your choice what would each of
you pick and why
well you know what i realized that i
didn't i think maybe maybe i went to one
bar mitzvah but i went to an all girls
catholic school so it's a bot mitzvah
well no oh no
it's not a
right they weren't jewish no right right
right there were nuns so that wasn't
really and if they were they were like
not inviting the class to it because
they didn't want people to know that
they were jewish
but i think i went to one
and it was like i was going with a
friend
from a different school to one of their
friends bar mitzvah right and meeting
new people oh yeah that's really so i
don't know but i guess i would
probably do like
satan themed oh great i will go to that
bond that would be
sexy
i feel like vanessa you do also satan no
i swear i don't know but i feel like you
do music or like well i would do one of
those ones where like you put like
everyone has their own pair of
headphones oh yes yeah you've done that
yes and then i would do probably like a
punk theme or something oh that
sounds really great that's like a silent
disco you've you've really thrown that
party
you've thrown oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i love this scene you have to do
that that sounds so fun a punk themed
silent disco where you look like you're
listening to pop music but really it's a
24 karat magic
[Laughter]
cooper what you going for uh bruno mars
okay okay well all three of these
options are way cooler than perry's
plaza because i was obsessed with the
mall i know i will never forget it that
sounds really fun though that's pretty
cool
back in the day i might switch it up to
satan now that's a really good idea uh
cooper for you so making your very first
feature is a big deal it's a very
challenging thing to pull off but
getting your second feature off the
ground can be equally as challenging so
what would you say was the key thing you
did between [ __ ] and this that got
cha-cha real smooth the green light i
found dakota johnson i got unassumed
with her i got on a zoom with her
producing partner ro donnelly and i told
her about an idea from movie i told her
about a title and then ro told dakota
there's a movie called cha cha real
smooth and she was like all right
finally i'll meet well no first i was
like i'm doing it also i'll meet him
so we met and she was in greece and it
was really uh late night for her and we
hit it off and we were off to the races
makes me very happy to hear that so i
was also reading that the two of you
workshopped a lot of stuff on set and
you wanted to have that kind of
spontaneity when you're preparing scenes
and working on dialogue and stuff like
that so is there any particular scene
that i can see in the finished film
where something changed on the spot last
minute and it changed for the better all
of them
yeah yeah a lot most of our stuff
was
we just either like
deepened things or took out
fluff
stuff
and we were we were even in scenes like
sometimes right before a scene we would
look at the page and be like let's
rewrite it but even some like during a
scene i feel like dakota would say
something and we'd go down a bit of a
different path and it
was always trying to figure out what was
the most alive
dangerous
funniest but
still saying what we want the scene to
say great success in that department
vanessa for you i'm very curious in real
life are you really good at bananagrams
no
i don't think i've played in four years
i found it to be the most boring game
ever why would i ever want to play that
it was originally supposed to be
scrabbled but i think we couldn't
clear that yeah
i love banana grams and i'm kind of good
at it and my family won't play with me
anymore oh i i love bananagrams it's a
little like it's kind of stressful but
it is it keeps you on your toes that's
the best part uh vanessa your first film
here and you're working with some of the
best of the best is there anything you
saw cooper dakota do on set that you
thought was really cool and you want to
try on your next movie uh-huh it's okay
to say well if i say no it is that bad
no it's not at all you can say no not
really i felt fine as myself
there were certain things that uh
vanessa did that i think we yeah would
take for everything yeah i actually
think that's probably the best answer to
that question i can imagine for sure
yeah i like the idea of believing in
yourself and your own craft there
uh dakota for you i always get very
thrilled when i see actors with really
big platforms starting to put their
weight behind the movies they believe in
as a producer so cha cha real smooth is
one of the first for you why did you
want that to be one of the first and
what are some of your priorities in
producing going forward
i think chacho was one of the first
films that basically was ready to go
like
when we when we finished
writing
um
we were able to make it it was during
the pandemic i was available everybody
else was available so that one was
ready the uh my company has i really had
to check my schedule
yeah you really we really have to move
some things around
jostle his schedule
um i felt like
my company makes really specific movies
and very authentic very we really
believe in um telling the truth and
telling
stories with
um that have real grounded characters
and real authentic characters in them
and this
just was
so much that
and um
i really love producing i love being
involved in making a movie from the
beginning to the very end whereas
as an actress i don't have that luxury
so
it's really really
amazing to be able to make my own movies
now i'm very excited for you in that
department and starting here is quite
strong you guys really accomplished
something else before they get me out of
here i wanted to squeeze in one madame
web question just because i feel like
you're excited
but i i am curious because one of the
reasons why you're one of my favorite
actors out there is because of the the
films you've done particularly in the
last five years just like really bold
unique one-of-a-kind films that are made
on a bit of a smaller scale compared to
something like that so is there anything
about your experience working on those
types of films since doing something
like 50 shades need for speed that now
has changed your approach to working on
a big studio feature like that
i don't know i guess having
experience um
on all tiers of films i i
can bring um
maybe some stuff from the little movies
to the big movies that i i want to see
in them you know i really love seeing
like large scale films that still have
heart in them and
um we love top gun we love top gun
everyone loves top gun i love top gun
yeah everyone does exactly like top gun
i want to make top gun tom cruise also
you're bringing some cats over
all right and cats some of the math
two two madame webb are you from top gun
no
are you raising some people from i am
bringing some people i'm directing
madame webb yeah i mean now i'm even
more at now you know
no and like
even people from chacha and some from am
i okay
are coming on to madame webb with me
it's cool it's fun to be able to start
creating like a real team of
people that make movies i was really
excited when i thought cats meant like
furry cats yeah like those cats are cool
i was like i'm drinking some cats
a dog i am bringing zeppelin for sure
and some cats
love to hear it i mean it this is one of
my favorite movies of the year huge
congratulations and thank you for your
time thank you so much
you